this video was made possible by better
help.com / Pakman where you can get
affordable online access to a licensed
therapist through text phone and video
chat
just click the link under this video
this is a really bizarre story I don't
really know any other word for it we've
talked about the sort of macro insanity
of the Brett Kavanaugh sexual assault
story we now have multiple allegations
against him from Christine Blasi Ford
from Deborah Ramirez there are
allegations that Cavanaugh was involved
in flying women along with others with
alcohol in order to as a pretext to the
possible gang rape of these women he
made a very strange statement where he
said he definitely wasn't at the party
where Christine Blasi Ford was allegedly
almost raped but how would you know you
weren't at that specific party if it
didn't happen and you weren't there
there's none of it really makes sense
right that's the macro of it so anyway
we're waiting on the hearing to see what
dr. Ford has to say to hear Brett
Cavanaugh's defense senators have been
sort of working out exactly when it's
going to be and in the middle of this
Republican Senator Chuck Grassley
appears to have accidentally tweeted
something that he meant to text to Brett
Kavanaugh Grassley is 85 years old he's
the chair of the Senate Judiciary
Committee meaning he's running the
confirmation hearings for Cavanaugh to
the Supreme Court he's running the
scheduling he's making decisions about
what's happening when and late on Friday
close to midnight Eastern Time on Friday
he tweets the following quote judge
Cavanaugh I just granted another
extension to dr. Ford to decide if she
wants to proceed with the statement she
made last week to testify to the Senate
she should decide so we can move on I
want to hear her I hope you understand
it's not my normal approach to be
indecisive this doesn't really read like
a normal public tweet that a senator
would deliberately send at midnight it
reads more to me like this was supposed
to be a private text message to Brett
Kavanaugh at the same time Grassley does
tweet in generally confusing
unclear ways so like here's another
example of Grassley's shorthand that he
has used in tweets he once tweeted quote
five times now we've granted extension
for dr. Ford to decide if she wants to
proceed with her desire stated one week
ago that she wants to tell the senator
story dr. Ford if you changed your mind
say so so we can move on I want to hear
your testimony come to us or we to you
so on the one hand it does seem like his
first message was meant to be like a
private text to Brett Kavanaugh on the
other hand particularly for an 85 year
old guy who was not necessarily raised
in the era of social media shorthand he
does seem to regularly use some pretty
consistent shorthand everything about
this story is bizarre down to the
communications between Grassley and
cabin ah yeah they looked into the
character count on that first tweet yeah
it was 272 just 8 character shy of the
280 Twitter limit yeah so that suggests
to me that he wrote it up and then had
to delete some characters and so maybe
he thought he was tweeting but that's
that's not something that you want
release to the public that's something
you tell someone one-on-one yeah yeah
maybe he thought it was a direct message
I don't know there's so many questions
here do you think he's direct messaging
with Brett Kavanaugh that would be even
more shocking maybe this is the
transparency we've been waiting for like
instead of communicating with Kavanaugh
privately Grassley does it through
public Twitter posts just directed at
Kavanaugh and as far as the subject
matter in Grassley's defense although he
might be sort of stumbling around in the
dark technologically he does actually
seem to want to get the hearing done
with the Cavanaugh accuser but he wants
to get it done merely to say we did it
we we heard from her and now we're ready
to confirm Brett Kavanaugh to the
Supreme Court and of course we now have
even more information to suggest that
that's what they want to do because we
learned that last week they were
notified about the existence of a second
accuser Deborah Ramirez and instead of
saying stop the presses stop this from
going forward we've got to go back to
the drawing board and investigate all of
the stuff Republicans instead said oh
we've got to hurry up we've got to hurry
up and get Cavanaugh approved for life
to the Supreme Court confirmed for life
before this blows up in our faces
now I want to give you one example of
what I mean
when I say Republicans don't care what
Christine Blasi Ford says they just want
to say we heard from her now we're ready
to move on Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham Graham says it doesn't matter
what she says he's not going to change
his vote the hearing hasn't happened but
he's saying the content of it is
irrelevant he said on Fox News Sunday
yesterday quote you can't bring it in a
criminal court you would never sue
civilly you couldn't even get a warrant
what am I supposed to do go ahead and
ruin this guy's life based on an
accusation I don't know when it happened
I don't know where it happened and
everybody named in regard to being there
said it didn't happen there's a huge
difference between ruining his life and
simply saying he shouldn't be one of
nine appointed for life judges on the
highest court in the land right that's
not the same thing I can't ruin his life
by not buying him a Lamborghini well
there's a difference between ruining
someone's life and not getting them the
luxury sports car that they want right
and the point is the Republicans who
want the hearing don't want it because
they might hear what dr. Ford has to say
and then decide you know what I can't
vote for this guy they want to do it
just so they can check the box say they
did it and move on to confirm confirming
him I don't think any Republicans are
willing to change their votes
yeah and Lindsey Graham is making it
seem as though we're prosecuting
Cavanaugh and are proving these
allegations beyond a reasonable doubt
sure that's not what the standard is
here it's just weighing it out out in
the court of public opinion and among
those 100 senators who will vote to
confirm and making a decision as to
whether they are comfortable giving this
guy a job for life deciding the most
important legal cases out there period
for the United States for as long as he
wants to be on the court the answer is
clearly now